all right welcome everybody
why am i here so early today trump's not
scheduled to start
for more than 20 minutes the reason is i
have a heart out at 6
30 p.m eastern time and oh my god
there's a cable blocking my uh
hold on give me a second folks i'm gonna
be just give me one second
embarrassing tech issue
okay let's take it from the top i had a
uh i had a cable
literally draped across my camera shot
if you can imagine something so
embarrassing anyway i'll see you guys
later that's the stream no no we're just
getting started um donald trump does
appear
that he is going to be starting on time
he actually often when when something is
scheduled trump will then tweet that
it's really
starting 15 30 or 45 minutes later trump
just tweeted that we are scheduled for
the top of the hour
hopefully we will get to see the bulk of
this together because i have a hard
out at 6 30 p.m eastern time
i have fresh memes and
i have for you a new jessie lee peterson
interview
this is not going to be published to
youtube until later
but i might be convinced depending on
how the next 10 minutes go
to show you guys some elements
of this 35 minute jessie lee peterson
interview
it is nuts it is nuts he confesses
celibacy
in this interview okay so this is going
to be something people are really really
going to want to see
um super chats are coming in twitch
subscriptions are coming in
i have memes i have so many things i
don't even know where to start
um other than maybe hold on let's just
get one meme out of the way
oh okay i guess this is anime pacman
so i don't know i don't know what people
think of this one but i i don't think
it's bad it was good enough to make it
onto the stream let me put it that way
but um you know i don't know how much
people like it
but that's uh it's interesting it's
interesting nonetheless
i am not going to start with the jesse
lee peterson stuff if i'm going to be
convinced
to do that i want to wait until there
are more people on the stream so more
more more people see it i do want to say
thanks to stefan grimm
because he just signed up on my website
and his new member number one today
which i appreciate
all right let's see what's on people's
minds here um
okay steve waterstone sent about a
hundred dollars worth of super chats
before we even started
and there's so much that i can't even
deal with it right now i'm gonna have to
look at that offline and then maybe i'll
send steve a message
uh because it's just it's like 20 super
chats it's crazy
i i love it i appreciate it but it's
just a lot
chakuseki says if trump wins i'm going
to drown myself in a vat of ice cold
plasma and have my body hurled into a
forest of exploding trees
careful with that steve does add if i
can ever do anything from australia to
help for real change then please ask
also if anyone wants to know about
australia then shout out
after corona i will be looking for
barbers and pay well
okay very good steve chakaseki also
coming back in with the message beware
if one pump chump donald trump doesn't
win president dumpy lump will declare
narcian law narshan law
ajamu omawale says talk about brianna
taylor yeah so tomorrow we're going to
talk about the decision in terms of
charges with brianna taylor
there are also protests growing in
kentucky
and there is the idea there there is the
uh um
i don't want to use the word fear there
is
a sense that protests could escalate
significantly um later on today
and i who if things get really wild i
may be back for a second stream later
jake vx says what are your thoughts on
chris wallace picking the topics for the
upcoming presidential debate on tuesday
i'm not i didn't know that he was
picking the topics i thought that
the commission on presidential debates
was going to be involved
but uh i i have no concerns about topic
choice for tuesday's debate
steve leon says yesterday you said dr
amin was the doctor chosen by the trump
administration for for sterilization
upon what information are you basing
that claim
well it's the doctor contracted by
trump's ice
uh and if you believe that the buck
stops with the president it's happening
under donald trump's watch that's what i
meant
daraten says david exploding trees
antifa next door invisible planes this
all follows fox news opinion shows
the night before trump isn't that
original absolutely
you can look at the timing of trump's
tweets and what's on fox news
and make some very precise deductions
let me put it that way
thank you to show aaron for subscribing
with twitch prime
your subscriber 1032
on twitch which i appreciate nicolas
silva
says david if a super duper tree in a
democrat-run forest is hit by a bag of
soup
does it even explode that's really a
metaphysical question
uh more than more than anything else a
good question but a metaphysical one
firewall cmd has also subscribed with
prime
which i appreciate how long does the
number take to update because it's been
about 30 seconds already like how long
does it take to go to 1033
i didn't realize it took this long
that's weird
let's see huh still a thousand thirty
two that's odd
i didn't realize that there was that
that much of a delay that's interesting
what can you oh there it is okay
beautiful okay
let's do a couple of memes just as
people uh join uh join the party
as many of you know we recently hit 1
million subscribers on
youtube and youtube sent me a beautiful
red velvet cake for 30 people
um and yesterday i said i will put the
picture up but i want
memes send me memes
and um i got a bunch of them okay so
let's look at some of them
here is sort of like an infinite
regression of me
in the painting and the cake says get
out and vote
not bad not bad here's another one
where i guess the idea is that i have a
painting up a poster up in my place
of um various authoritarian
dictators and leaders not bad
here is trump with black hair
staying humble trump 2020 with a bust of
trump
cash a gilded chandelier
and trump photoshopped into the picture
behind me
that's not bad here is just a different
thing on the cake i reached 1 million
subscribers and all i got was this cake
all right democracy is ending but here's
a cake
okay i believe this is by far the best
one
i think that it is you know with total
peace and love to everybody who
participated
to me this is so far and away the best
one
uh this would be like a future party
where i have a beard and a much older we
reach
nars some people know it as mars trump
called it nars
and as you can see i have a painting a
tribute
to convalescent plasma on the screen
behind me i think this is the best
by far and then one other one this one's
just kind of weird there's a naked
andrew yang
like imagine if i had art on the wall at
my place of a naked andrew yang that
would be crazy
uh but not bad i think that this is like
the second best
i would go if i had to rank them i would
say
number one is this one bearded pacman
who reached nars
and then number two oh it's the
terminator right he's in the terminator
pose yeah yeah yeah
um number two would be terminator andrew
yang i don't know if you guys agree with
my rating but this is like really good
work and i'm still taking submissions
and future contributions are
very very much welcome i like this aged
david pakman much better than some of
the others that people have sent me
when you run my face through one of
those uh
apps that ages you it's really bad
i like this like this is a great look
it's sort of a cross between
kind of like a jon stewart um
yeah i'll just go with jon stewart i
don't think that this is bad but this is
number one
this is number two all of the others i
think are relatively
uh on you know equal but number one and
number two
if you have submissions you can send
them to me
at uh using the use imager links
using davidpakman.com contact form okay
that's the way to do it
thanks to joanne helmer who's new member
number
two today and victoria clemente who is
new member number three
very much appreciate that super chats
are coming in powerfully
kyle's says from australia just viewed
dr
fauci at hearing so good steve lyon
says you specifically said trump chose
amin for sterilization
the trump administration okay the trump
administration
grace weiland says what are your
thoughts about the trump rep deposition
videos that were released
honestly i didn't take much time to
watch them uh i
i don't know i mean you know trump's out
of his mind what else can i say
game roth says i love i know you're
friends with joe rogan but are you
concerned with what can be perceived as
a subtle but certain transition to the
trump
and the right i i actually don't know
what you're referring to
in that i don't really watch any shows
so i don't if there's something specific
that happened on rogan's show i would
love to know about it
unknown prodigy says attention i am
about to lie
for 37 minutes straight please sit
without your mask and enjoy the show
yeah that's exactly what it says here on
these pieces of paper
behind the seats dina asked whether
there's a chance canada will take
legitimate refugees prior to the
election
also can y'all annex the dakotas
uh that's a question for canadians i
wouldn't be able to answer that
but i i do appreciate the message we are
in the middle of a hype train on twitch
i do want to welcome
fearless freckles and computes guys you
know what i'm feeling fired up
let's do the jesse lee peterson
interview okay
i was uh last time i was with jesse lee
peterson in los angeles california
i went to his christian counseling
center and the video got a million views
on my youtube channel i interviewed him
earlier today
the entire interview the entire
interview is
36 minutes long i am going to play
three clips for you but here is here's
the my ask okay
people in the chat tell me if you can
agree to this
people are already i haven't even told
you what what i need you to agree to i
haven't even
people are i get i love that people are
agreeable but here's the deal
please generate clips remixes
edits and memes based on this interview
please please please do it because this
is just ripe
ripe ripe for material and let me make
one more ask
if the three clips i preview for you
right now tickle your fancy
get a membership at jointpakman.com okay
that's my that's my request to you
clip number one jessie lee peterson and
david pakman filmed earlier today to be
published later today
are you a christian pastor i am yes you
are and what what denomination
non-denominational christian okay and i
remember that your studio in la people
may find this interesting
is it also some kind of christian
counseling center
do i remember that correctly where you
counsel young men
yeah but uh not in the studio we have i
have my offices
upstairs and so we we counsel in in
house and
by skype or telephone or by phone
whichever is easy for the folks
that's fascinating and so now you're
you're not like a therapist right you're
not a social worker or a psychologist or
anything like that
no just a counselor okay and that's
in california that's an unregulated
credential right anybody can use that
term
well you have to you have to be a
minister or pastor or something like
that
and you can do counseling under the hand
in them people pointing out i'm wearing
the same shirt it was filmed 90 minutes
ago yeah of course it's
from today i'm wearing the same shirt
your ministry wow and that
insurance doesn't cover that right it
does it does
in california you can go to a counselor
who's just a minister and
it's considered a medical visit one
hundred percent doesn't matter okay
this is one topic okay i think that that
the the future of this topic is very
interesting and i look forward for
people checking it out
okay another clip i'm doing three
preview clips
all right and if people like it and sign
up maybe we'll even publish this earlier
here's another topic
i asked him about policy it didn't go
well
and when you talk about the job that
trump has done
just to pick something to really dig
into and make this a you know i want to
take the interview seriously and
you know hopefully it won't devolve the
way some of the prior interviews have
let's take economics and taxation for
example
do you like the trump tax plan and if so
what do you like about
it well that's why i like the fact that
he is
cut back on taxes and giving more money
to the workers
rather than taking it i like the fact
that he
um has made it easier for small
businesses to get going
even though we have a chinese virus
situation right now so the economy
uh has stopped a little bit but it's
starting to come back
and dude what what's the regulations but
let's pick something
let's pick one thing what has trump done
to make
it easier for businesses to get going
by cutting back on so many rules and
regulations that the democrat had
established
like what what's an example of such a
such i don't have anything in mind
right now yeah but a lot of the rules of
regulation that was preventing
uh uh small businesses from starting
yeah have been taken away by the great
white home what would be but so give me
just i don't i know that there's dozens
and dozens but what's one such rule
that was taken away that now makes it
easier to start a business
nothing come to mind right now it is
there anything that you can remember
even
seeing at any time nothing come tomorrow
nothing
wow that's amazing amazing yeah
uh okay all right so let's stick with
economics just
i'll we'll do one more question on this
for a moment what do you think the top
marginal tax rate should be for
for top earners
good question man i don't know i haven't
thought about it at this point
is it too high or too low currently so
no
i'm sorry wouldn't you say your phone
went off for a minute what'd you say
i said do you think the current top
marginal tax rate is too high or too low
i'm not sure at this time david you're
not sure so how do you know
that trump's tax plan is good if you
don't even know what tax rates are and
how he changed them
well because i have not been focusing on
that lately i have more important things
to think about
okay i think you can so i'm going to
stop here because this is just a preview
i think you guys get a sense of the way
that went let's now go
okay i'm going to skip sort of to the
end and i'm going to give you guys one
more preview
let me just see if trump has started he
hasn't started okay we don't want to
miss this
we're going to do one more clip okay
take a listen to this
jesse listen you really said it all uh i
i do want to just ask about one more
thing our audience may or may not know
you're you're in your 70s are what are
are you drinking
pomegranate what are you doing in order
to keep that glow
i don't have any anger in my heart i
only have love which come from god
and when you don't have anger you're not
stressed out you're not
worried you're not having suicidal
thought you're not comparing yourself to
others
you're not trying to be like anyone else
you are yourself
you're in a perfect peaceful place
within yourself
so you're not comparing yourself to
anyone when you don't have anger that's
why you have to overcome anger if you
want perfect peace
what so it's not like you've switched to
turkey bacon or you eat a lot of fruit
or have
kind of some special skin it's just
you're just not an angry guy
no i don't have anger so i'm not under
stress
and you don't attribute any of it to
diet
no i do work out you know i exercise i
eat
in moderation now but i do it because
you know i have a self-control now i
don't have to give in to all that stuff
and plus i don't have anger so i'm not
trying to fulfill my
an ego right most people who are out of
control and the way they eat
have sex use pot and drink they have an
ego problem they have an anger
problem that's why we show people how to
overcome that anger
so they can have peace within themselves
then they would do all things in
moderation
wow and are you are you off sex all
together now
i am you are because i'm not only
because i'm not married
if i was married i would not be offset
wow that's a revelation i think the
audience will find compelling that's
very very interesting
so guys um as you can see
this is uh a tre it's a veritable
treasure trove of memetic content
and i need the clips i need remixes
i need memes send me the stuff because
it is wild okay it is wild wild wild
i i was willing to do a real interview
but i how else he doesn't know anything
about
politics so i had to just you know i had
to just troll the entire time it was
really wild
we did get into whether i'm beta i mean
it's 36 minutes of memes so
this we're going to publish it at 6 45
in about 45 minutes
send it around i would love it if some
other streamers
reviewed it i think it just has such
potential you have no
idea the potential of this from the
standpoint
of memes it is wild wild wild stuff
uh we are standing by for donald trump
scheduled for the top of the hour and we
will see
um where we come out in terms of the
start time
i'm worried that there's not too many
people in the room as i mentioned before
just so we're all clear i have a hard
out at 6
30 p.m eastern so hopefully they start
soon because
uh come hell or high water as i've heard
people say
um bottom of the hour it's go time
for me yeah i would love for hassan to
watch it and everybody yeah send it send
it around my friends 6 45 it's going
live
okay as we stand by for donald trump i
have a very small request to make of you
it's a very powerful request it's a very
moral request it's an ethical request
consider grabbing a membership on my
website joinedpakman.com
i have condensed the membership hard
excuse me hard sale
into 45 seconds per stream that's all we
do
and i will give you just the facts
memberships are cheap
they feel good they are easy average
computer proficiency
makes it only a 45 second process to get
a membership
and sorry i forgot where i was going
there
no and you can save 66 by using the
coupon code right above me 20 20 now
you go to joinpakman.com you just sign
up
that's it it just it feels great and it
is our number one funding source so for
example
thanks to conrad alro who is new member
number
four at joinpackman.com we had
56 new members yesterday and it was
a stunning day it was a beautiful
beautiful day
so consider grabbing those memberships i
will thank
everybody i can before trump starts and
the counter continues climbing even once
the press briefing starts so you don't
have to worry about that too much
uh okay let me see here
betazoid says posted you a cake meme
front page of your subreddit okay yeah
i'll have to check that out after
uh mars v says he seems like a stable
genius
zachary foster says fauci han
and redfield did say in the hearing
today that if safe
and effective he would likely have 700
million doses by april 2021.
beautiful i hope that's true jacob
brattner says did you see the sonic meme
on the subreddit although
thoughts on a super conservative
majority in supreme court
giving election to trump oh also
thoughts tomorrow i'm going to deal with
the supreme court giving the election to
trump i did not see the sonic meme
on the subreddit i'm bookmarking all of
these things
to look at later uh oh my god people
have already put
nug our friend nug wrangler over on
twitch
he has already posted um
the new jessie lee peterson interview
cannot upload fast enough just finished
watching the first half tons of nasty
questions from david
the beginning was basically jesse i like
what trump did on x david can you cite a
specific thing trump did on x that you
like
jesse no i cannot uh oh man
this it is it is just a treasure trove i
don't see
my concern is that not everybody will
see i think the interview is
wild but hopefully people will see it
because it is just out of control
yeah i like this this is just lovely and
we're up for oh i'm not logged in
anyway so that'll be coming later uh it
it gets very very nasty particularly in
the
in the middle parts thanks to kimchi who
has subscribed with prime with the
message
beta badaboom pat
has subscribed with twitch prime
as well which i love
uh levi manion says
your thoughts about the report trump's
campaign have contingencies
in the way of placing their own electors
to decide the popular vote in swing
states
that's an atlantic article published
today i'm doing 15 minutes on that
tomorrow on the show
so i don't want to jump ahead but yeah
it's it's wild
we're going to talk about that tomorrow
i want to say thanks to
rihanna sullivan rihanna sullivan is new
member number five today
at joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that
let's see if we have any other um
oh my god that we don't want that here
we go this is where we want to be
um all right other super chats
let's see here um
t oh no i'm not gonna fall for that okay
this user hi cutie you're a total enigma
in the lgbt community you're super hairy
like a bear
but built like a total twink you're this
amazing hybrid we call a [ __ ]
wow that's crazy yeah
too bad i'm not gay it sounds like i'd
be i'd be part of multiple communities
if i were part of the lgbtq
uh space so to speak
jason nadal says can't help but be
scared about the results of the election
the stress is aging me i
understand i understand
let's see dave kaplan says keep up the
good work dave you are a bright light in
the vast
darkness that is 2020. thank you
cktkc says do you think trumpers could
have literally fallen in love with trump
hence their lack of any questioning of
trump to some degree i mean
it's more of a cult-like following than
romantic love
that's the way i would say it a big
thank you to nathan
chan who's new member number six
ruben dominguez is new member number
seven
michael mazur is new member number eight
and devin barr is new member number nine
i really do appreciate that guys very
very much so
people demanding demanding one more jlp
clip
all right let's do one more i'm just
gonna pick a random moment
in the middle let's just see what was
going on at this moment
anything you don't like that donald
trump has done
i don't know how much i agree with him
or letting the inmates out of the
prisons
uh uh which inmates which inmates are
those
which are which inmates are those you
know how they let a lot of the uh
prisons out by saying that they were
there because they sold pot
or their crime wasn't bad enough to keep
them
in prison some kind of dumb stuff like
that you don't know how much i support
that because i haven't had time to
really
look into that i just feel that
if you do the crime you should do the
time and it doesn't matter what color
you are
right i'm in total support of that
and did you yeah and one other one that
might
might make you feel good on the inside
um
i don't like the fact that when he
right now there's a position open on the
u.s supreme court
yes i don't like all right so we're
gonna stop there it looks like uh
oh that's just john roberts okay i
thought it was actually trump starting
okay so anyway that's all going to
publish uh
at the 45 past the hour and we want the
memes my friends if there is a if i've
ever done anything
meme worthy it is this interview okay
other super chats coming in
paper x mario says have you made any
videos about louisville even today more
arrests have been happening i'm actually
heading to barclays at seven because of
the outrage
tomorrow we're to cover that tomorrow
but yeah i'm following it very closely
uh proton jinx says are you worried the
pacman show is a shooting star because
of trump and would lose its relevance or
place once
trump is gone no you know it's funny
when we uh started the show
george w bush was president and when
bush lost and obama won people wrote to
me and said david do you think you can
keep growing the show
now that a democratic president is
president and i said i think we can
and during barack obama's two terms we
had the biggest growth to date of the
david pakman show
then when donald trump won there was the
idea that
disaffected liberals are going to bail
on programs because everybody is just
disaffected and you know sad and all
this stuff
and we've had huge growth under donald
trump and now the exact same thing is
coming up which is is your show going to
be able to persist
if joe biden wins and i believe that the
answer is yes there will be endless
things happening
the transition period will be crazy no
matter what the first part of 2021 is
going to be wild regardless then you're
going to have republicans reinstating
their obama-era obstructionism and
complete outrage
i i think think american politics are
going to be crazy for a long time
um now i do believe we would be better
the show would do better financially if
trump won
it would be immoral for me to support
trump i would never do something like
that
trump's a disaster and i want him to
lose and i'm voting for biden
i recognize if trump wins the show
likely does better than under biden but
i think
we will continue to do well in either
case
and uh there's always news there's
always things going on there's always a
way to push forward
oh i'm being notified that we hit 1.01
million subscribers we did oh my
goodness we did it
um that's right so we hit a million
subscribers about 10 days ago
we now have hit 1.01 million
on youtube which i love and we are
200 followers away from 50k on twitch
you understand what i'm saying 50 000
followers on twitch is within striking
distance we are
205 away
and 1.01 million on youtube i know it
has a nicer ring to it
okay jim clark asks whether i was live
when we hit a million subscribers not
only was i not live we were on vacation
yeah but katie bradshaw says
religiously integrate cog
behavioral therapy isn't bad
okay uh the brian boru has subscribed
with twitch thoticus botticus
has subscribed with prime
um freedomman2012 with a message i'm
gonna sound like bill uh bill o'reilly
i'm gonna pronounce it the way bill
o'reilly pronounced it
hey david can you give a shout out to my
buddy
haywood jablom okay that when bill
o'reilly got trolled with that one
that's that's how he pronounced it
um thanks to almost equal
and storn away store no way
for subscribing over on twitch which i
very much appreciate
um a few other subscribers to thank
miranda smith is new member number 10
john hagen is number 11. history
onik is number 12. randy
ward is number 13. terry felton
is number 14 and miguel felipe
de carvalho mendes is number
uh 16. very very
nice i appreciate that seems like a
portuguese or brazilian name
if i uh if i had to say
we are standing by for donald trump just
so people don't you know get
pissed off i only have until the bottom
of the hour so we'll see how much we
are able to see uh during that period of
time i have a hard
out but i may be back later with
kentucky related streams
chef's pawn congratulating me on a
million subscribers via super chat
gary cavin says i played a drinking game
last month taking a shot every time
trump trump says imagine that i just now
came to yeah
uh maddie ice wants me to shout out
richard hertz
richard thank you
examine everything says great show trump
is a crazy mofo who gotta go
john howell says david's a [ __ ] i guess
he is confident in bington
my god look there's someone reading the
washington post in front of us
it's actually in the shot what is this
person doing
very interesting very very interesting
super guy says many states are going to
count mail-in ballots early could this
prevent the red mirage yes it could
it could it very much could
um jose de la rosa wants to know if
biden's health care plan covers
counseling sessions at jesse lee
peterson's
counseling center god i hope not god i
hold down
caroline clark says in vu
for invu
for you are a cutie i think i got it
very nice caroline thank you chris house
says did you like the maga hat meme with
covet cake
uh magga hat meme with covet cake
i don't know which one that is taco meme
says keep it up man your channel is
great
thank you i appreciate the support
uh tom ty also checking in from the uk
curious to hear your thoughts on your
experience as a umass amherst student i
studied there for a year as an exchange
listen it was a great experience for me
because i was looking for a big school
experience i have lots of friends who
went to small liberal arts schools
and it's a totally different experience
you know your teachers in a different
way when there aren't 400 people in some
of your classes
i wanted the big school experience i
then had the smaller
school experience in uh in grad school
and i had some great professors i had
richard wolff as a professor when i was
at umass in the economics department i
had
the the late great uh steve resnick who
has passed away
since um when i was in the economics
department
at the university of massachusetts
amherst so i had a great experience yeah
it's but you know it depends on what
you're looking for it's a very personal
thing
thanks to red red rum socks
for subscribing with prime w x
x z lol for subscribing with prime
if we get to 25 members will i do
another jessie lee peterson clip
we might be there right now let's see
pat needham is number 17.
kenneth schreiber is number 18. ross
daniels is number 19
dana jim is number 20. arnulfo velazquez
is number 21.
ryan bailey is number 22. raelynn
hillard is number 23.
gregory sexton is number 24 and
david kessel is number 25. all right
i'll do a little more of jlp i don't
want to play the entire thing but before
you know it it's like
i'll have played the whole thing but
let's just look at another
random moment from the jessie lee
peterson interview
they have illogical mindsets just like
their mother and just like women
so it's almost like you've you've almost
taken
a a bit of a freudian approach and
like perverted it into sort of like your
your your
christian view of that is is that am i
sort of on to the the
the ideology here well i have not
perverted it even god said that we must
be born again
yeah you were born of the woman and
anyone who's born of the woman
is dying but those who are born of the
spirit of god
are living anyway so so as you guys can
tell just like any random moment
we jump into it's completely crazy
oh someone says they sent me a jessie
lee peterson meme i'm going to look at
all of that stuff later
um yeah but get get memes and clips by
all means we want them we want them very
strongly in
okay um 72
marshflower says the trump cult is a
result of mass
psychogenic illness please look it up
okay
cat says the infinite monkey theorem
couldn't come up with a trump health
care plan
all right grant logan just says david
stubbs the wolf says have you thought
about getting into politics or do you
prefer to sit on the sidelines you know
interesting story about that
um a few months ago
i guess no it was before coveted
probably like
10 months ago someone came to me
uh here in massachusetts political
strategist who has run a lot of local
campaigns and said david you should run
for congress
you could use your platform and you
could run for congress
and i said well but who would i run
against because in massachusetts
i think in all states you don't have to
live in the district where you run
so you know i wouldn't necessarily have
to run in the district i live in
and they pointed to a very particular
member of congress in massachusetts
saying
this is who you should run against and i
think that you would actually have a
shot
but and they said you have to start
you know getting involved in local
politics you've got to go to democratic
town meetings you've got to do all this
stuff and it's like i just don't have
time for that and i don't know if i'm in
you know the amount of oversight the
amount it's like
i i'd really be complicating my life i
almost feel like trump
i'm enjoying what i'm doing right now uh
why would i complicate my life with that
but it is interesting it is interesting
uh oh what's going on now do we have is
anything happening
this is very very odd
where is that i guess trump's coming
soon uh so when oh two minute warning
okay
anyway um i've thought about getting
into politics i could never be president
though
i was not born in the united states
could never be president
thanks to kevin maguire who is new
member number 26 today at
joinedpakman.com
guys let's go for 50. let's do it uh
membership is our number one funding
source
we've got 26. let's do the 50. let's
just do it go to joinpakman.com
you see the coupon code above my head
people know how this stuff works
i don't think i have to uh i don't think
i have to convince too many people
uh let's see other super chats here
albic's oh here oh god it's kudlow
larry kudlow scott atlas behind
him and who is behind scott out is that
kaylee magananny
yes all right so we're probably gonna
need a little volume boost here
uh we are about to start here thanks to
a dumb plays for the raid with a party
of 78 people
i appreciate that very much
uh here is donald trump ladies and
gentlemen just a reminder i've got till
the bottom of the hour i'll tell you
guys when i've got to go
hello thank you very much thank you
[Music]
today johnson and johnson announced that
their vaccine candidate has reached the
final stage of clinical trials this is
record time
thank you this is the fourth vaccine
candidate in the united states to
actually today johnson and johnson
announced that their vaccine candidate
has reached the final stage of clinical
trials this is record time
this is the fourth vaccine candidate in
the united states
so the actual news today we did it on
the show it's that the fda now says it's
unlikely we're going to get anything
before the election that's the news
being a very positive word in this case
earlier this year johnson and johnson
anticipated that they would reach phase
one trials by september but due to our
support
under operation warp speed and to
some of the incredible scientists
involved they've reached
phase three trials by september far
ahead of schedule these are live we
encourage americans to enroll in the
vaccine trial
it's not only interesting it'll be a
terrific thing
for our country we encourage everybody
to enroll as many people as
we can today my administration announced
that we
are awarding 200 million dollars of
cares act funding
to all 50 states to prepare to
distribute the vaccine
to high-risk residents and we want to do
that
the instant it is approved not the
following day but the following moment
and so we're going to be doing that and
we'll be distributing getting it ready
because we have some
great vaccines going to be coming out
through operation warp speed
we also continue to accelerate
life-saving
therapies we are seeing promising
results that are
monoclonal antibody treatments which
help
the immune system fight the virus and
help very significantly refining can
reduce hospitalizations now by more than
70 percent by cutting red tape and
unleashing america's medical genius
we've reduced the fatality
rate 85 percent since april for
individuals under 50 they've
they have a 99.98 rate of survival
from the china virus that's a number
that's
been really increasing substantially
with time as children go back to school
we're encouraged that
early research shows only a small degree
of spread
brown university conducted a study of
more than 550 schools across 46 states
and found that only 0.076 percent of
students
had confirmed cases of the virus that's
a low entertaining
percentage and only 0.15
of teachers had confirmed cases patients
coming to the emergency room due to the
virus
is down to only 1.6 percent of all
emergency room
visits the lowest since the pandemic
began 1.6 emergency room
visits as far as
protecting the vulnerable is concerned
we provided over 21 billion dollars
to our nursing homes and we are really
focused on the nursing homes everybody
and
including our governors we have uh
governors are working very closely with
the
task force and with the vice president
and everybody involved
we've sent rapid testing devices to
nearly 14
000 certified nursing homes in the
country
this week we're sending hundreds of
thousands of additional rapid tests to
nursing homes to ensure they can
test staff regularly
and the staff now is being tested on a
very very powerful and
uh on a regular basis but uh
very strongly at the finest level the
highest level on the best tests
best encourage that the number of
americans getting the flu vaccine is
increasing by roughly
50 compared to last year substantially
up
always for it now the flu when it's
mixed with
covid or china virus is uh going to be
very interesting to see what happens but
interests that can drive numbers
and we just don't know what that will be
yet but you'll have flu numbers and
you'll have some covet numbers
i think we're rounding the turn very
much you see what's happening in europe
however they have a
very big spike countries that we thought
were doing well aren't doing well they
any day now very big spikes very
a very big surge months ago we
increased our nation's procurement of
the flu vaccine by 66 percent
and we ask americans to go get their
annual flu shot
as early as possible it's possible i
would imagine
scott that the flu can get mixed up with
the virus and make something people can
think it's the virus when actually it's
another flu season coming on
i don't know it's uh why we have flu
tests and cocaine separate can they keep
themselves yes they can
we hope so they will yes there's two
different tests it's going to be a
different interesting time but we have a
flu season coming
with the flu seasons which are um
really massive over the years over many
years and we have some that are
much less so but it's still significant
so i hope they can
separate them they can separate tests
it's pretty close
different times in the past four months
we've created 10.6 million jobs
we cut an employment rate nearly in half
the unemployment rate is cut nearly in
half larry kudlow is here he'll be
discussing that in a little while
retail sales are up 121
that's far above what we thought
manufacturing is up 61 percent that's
above
also above our schedule and our schedule
is a heavy schedule automobile
production
is up six-fold we thought
manufacturing is up 61 that's above
also above our schedule and our schedule
is a heavy schedule automobile
production
heavy is up six-fold homebuilders
sentiment is at the highest level in
history
that's an amazing statement larry the
highest level in history that means
people are thinking
good thoughts home sales are at the
highest level
in nearly 15 years small business
optimism is higher than any time
under the last administration
substantially higher
small business optimism higher than at
any time over the last
more than the last administration
today i was proud to award nine
companies and organizations with the
first ever pledge to america's workers
presidential award this
award recognizes outstanding training
programs that are
giving americans the skills to hone a
trade and earn a great living
great people over 5 400 companies have
competed and
committed to 16 million training
opportunities for the american worker
what energy and it's really been amazing
we've created the fastest economic
recovery in american history
you are witnessing it you're part of it
our approach is pro-science
biden's approach is anti-science if you
look it's
i don't think they know what their
approach is although a lot of us copied
from what we've done
biden opposed the china travel ban and
the europe travel ban
and the strategy that they have was just
never ending
lockdowns we're not locking down we're
very untrue growing at a rate that we've
never experienced before
but they're talking about if you have a
question just lock it down we're not
doing that
and you can't do that our plan will
crush the virus and
crush it actually biden's plan will
crush america if you think about it you
can't lock down
uh again we're growing at levels that
nobody's ever seen before our president
is unleashing a rapid recovery our
opponent's plan
would hurt america very badly send us
into a depression
and with all of that being said
we are going to be having a very
exciting
saturday at five o'clock in the rose
garden where i'll be putting forth
my nominee for supreme court justice
and i think it will be a uh a great
nominee a brilliant
real party as you know it's a woman
we've brought it down to five women
it's time for a woman to
uh to be chosen
with everything that's happened and with
justice ginsburg's
passing we are uh
going to go sometime tomorrow morning as
i understand it
to pay our respects and we'll be over
there and i guess they probably put that
announcement down but that will be done
tomorrow morning
the vice president was there today and
so
if you have any questions we'll take a
few questions
right here mr president uh real quickly
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today
for a peaceful trans referral of power
after the election and there has been
rioting in louisville there's been
rioting in many cities across this
country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful trans
pearl of power after the election well
we're gonna have to see what happens you
know that i've been concerned
very strongly about the ballots and the
ballots are a disaster
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very transformative
very peaceful cancel voting there won't
be a transfer
frankly there'll be a continuation the
ballots
are out of control you know it and you
know who knows it better than anybody
else the democrats know it better than
anybody else go ahead
the second question is will you please
go ahead
you ask any questions do you go after
the russians
say it mr president do you plan to meet
with barbara lagoa
at the white house i cannot hear you
with me
i'm sorry uh do you plan to meet with
barbara lego in washington
and is she still on your shortlist she
is on my list
i don't have a meeting planned uh but uh
she is on my list
uh i don't really talk about the
meetings planned i i speak to people i
talk to people
uh but i don't have a meeting plan do
you uh have a response to the governor
of missouri
uh testing positive for corona virus
i didn't know that no yeah okay yeah
not going to president um
we asked you earlier today about uh the
brianna taylor case yes can you
comment now i assume you've been briefed
on the charges in the book well i
thought it was
uh really brilliant uh kentucky attorney
general
daniel cameron is doing a fantastic job
i think he's a star
cameron spoke at the rnc if you guys
don't remember i'll just read
justice not justice is not often easy
it does not fit the mold of public
opinion and oh my god you can barely
read
to shifting standards it answers only to
the facts
and to the law if we simply act on
emotion or
outrage there's no justice mob justice
is not justice
justice sought by violence is not
justice
it just becomes revenge i mean i i heard
that i said write that down for me
please because i think it's
it was a terrific statement what is
wrong with you he's handling it
very well you know who he is right
you i think you know i think everyone
now knows who he is
i will be speaking to the governor and
we have a call scheduled to make very
shortly with the governor
i understand he's called up the national
guard which is a good thing i think it's
a very positive thing
and uh it'll all work out can i just
follow on your supreme court nominee
um it's highly unlikely that any
democrats will vote for your nominee
uh if it when it comes to a vote in the
senate
i think that's a pretty safe assumption
but
on that point would you want to nominate
someone who in their confirmation to the
appellate court
received broad bipartisan support or
would you be more inclined to put
forward somebody
whose confirmation fell along party
lines
i can't tell you what's going to happen
with the democrats i can say this the
person that i will be putting up and i
won't say that i've even
chosen that person yet i could say any
one of the five they're outstanding
women
but the person i'll be putting up is
highly qualified
highly brilliant top of the line
academic
student the highest credentials all of
them have that but
the highest credentials and you'll see
on saturday who that is i can't imagine
why a democrat wouldn't
vote for this person
yeah please go ahead thank you very much
no not you
we're right here president uh prince
harry and meghan markle
uh chimed did on the us election and
essentially encourage people to vote for
joe biden
i want to get your reaction to that
i'm not a fan of hers and of meghan
markle
i would say this and she probably has
heard that
but uh i wish a lot of luck
to harry because he's going to need it
mr president that's actually hilarious
probably considering
stricter guidelines for the uh emergency
authorization is out of his mind are you
okay with that
well i tell you what we're looking at
that that has to be approved by the
white house we may or may not approve it
that sounds like a political move
because when you have pfizer johnson and
johnson
modern are these great companies coming
up with these the vaccines and they've
done testing and everything else
i'm saying why would they have to be you
know adding
great length to the process we want to
have people not get sick the vaccine is
very important it's the final step i
believe it's going to be the final step
and no we're looking at that but i think
it's a i think that was a political move
more than anything else
on that sir it's designed
to improve trust in the vaccine do you
think that's not needed
well i have tremendous trust in these
massive
companies that are so brilliantly
organized in terms of what they've been
doing with the tests i mean
i don't know that a government as big as
we are could do tests like this we've
made it possible for them to do the
tests in rapid fashion
but when they come back and they say
that we have something that
works and absolutely works and they're
coming back with great numbers and
statistics and tests and everything else
that they have to come back with
i don't see any reason why it should be
delayed further because right if they
delete
delay in a week or two weeks or three
weeks
you know that's a lot of lives you're
talking about scott would you agree with
that or how do you feel about that
all right guys as i said i had until the
bottom of the hour and i'm gonna have to
run
um i will be potentially back later
today maybe covering some of what's whoa
this guy's a lot smaller than trump but
potentially covering what is going on
in kentucky um otherwise i'll see
everybody very very soon remember
like subscribe follow do any any
function that these various platforms
allow you to use
i encourage you very strongly to use it